Traduttore: Peggy-Anne Berthier
Revisore: Alessandra Tadiotto
Tutti noi abbiamo bisogno
di un posto dove sentirci al sicuro.
Un posto che ci trasmetta
un senso di protezione,
di tranquillità, di sicurezza.
Quel posto noi lo chiamiamo ‘casa’,
e riveste un ruolo
importantissimo per tutti noi.
È quel luogo dove ogni sera
vogliamo tornare dopo una giornata
di lavoro, di scuola
o di impegni frenetici
per lasciarceli alle spalle.
Chiudendo quella porta, vogliamo chiudere
dietro di noi tutti i problemi.
Lì, in quel luogo, ci vogliamo
sentire al riparo e al sicuro.
Seguitemi per un attimo
in questo piccolo esperimento.
In sala, tutti noi chiudiamo gli occhi.
Tutti con gli occhi chiusi.
E iniziate a immaginare
di essere a casa vostra.
Sono le nove di sera, siete tranquilli,
siete magari seduti a tavola
con i vostri familiari,
con i vostri cari e state cenando.
Oppure siete sul divano,
state guardando
la TV e vi state rilassando.
E poi sentite questo.
(AUDIO)
(FINE AUDIO)
Era il 6 maggio del 1976
quando una scossa di terremoto
di 6.5 di magnitudo colpì il Friuli.
Per puro caso, erano le nove di sera,
due registratori rimasero accesi
e registrarono l'audio
che abbiamo appena sentito.
Fu una scossa devastante,
tanto da essere ricordata poi, in seguito,
come una delle più tremende che colpì
l'Italia e da meritarsi un appellativo.
Forse qualcuno di voi in sala
se lo ricorderà o l’ha già sentito.
Venne definita l’Orcolat.
L’Orcolat è un termine dispregiativo
dialettale che sta a indicare
quell'essere a cui rimandiamo
le cause di quel terremoto. L’Orco.
Fu una scossa eccezionale,
fu sentita dal Centro al Nord Italia,
da Torino a Roma,
ma anche al di fuori
dei nostri confini italiani,
in parte della Germania, in Francia,
in Ungheria e in Slovacchia.
Portò devastazione in centoventi comuni,
non solo del Friuli Venezia Giulia
e del Veneto,
ma anche dell'Austria,
della Slovenia, della Croazia.
Un comune, probabilmente, in particolare
fu colpito: quello di Gemona,
dove un mio collega del Centro Comune
di Ricerca ha scattato questa foto.
Lui, immediatamente dopo quell'evento,
partì con la colonna
dei Vigili del Fuoco del Centro
- che allora si chiamava Euratom -
per prestare soccorso
alle popolazioni colpite.
Sì, perché a quel tempo non esisteva
la Protezione Civile,
non esistevano nemmeno delle normative
vere e proprie, innovative,
per costruire in una zona sismica.
Più di 40 anni sono passati
e tanta ricerca è stata fatta.
Tanto impegno
a livello mondiale e a livello europeo
per rendere i nostri edifici più sicuri.
Questo grazie anche all'impegno profuso
dal Centro Comune di Ricerca,
dove io lavoro.
Io e i miei colleghi lavoriamo in un
laboratorio per la valutazione strutturale
- che noi, più familiarmente,
chiamiamo ELSA -
dove testiamo edifici a scala reale,
alti fino a quattro piani.
ELSA è un laboratorio unico in Europa,
è il più grande del suo genere.
E lì, io e i miei colleghi
abbiamo una missione:
rendere più sicuri i nostri,
i vostri edifici.
E come lo facciamo?
Lo facciamo testando infrastrutture,
ponti, strutture prefabbricate
o strutture in cemento,
in calcestruzzo armato,
come quella che potete
vedere in questo video.
Qui (scusatemi…), qui,
in questo video abbiamo testato
un edificio in cemento armato
e abbiamo applicato a questo edificio
di quattro piani delle azioni,
le stesse azioni che si possono
sviluppare durante un sisma,
un sisma anche di notevole entità,
per andare a valutare come
questo edificio potesse comportarsi,
o le tecniche e i materiali
e le tecnologie che abbiamo applicato
potessero migliorare le sue prestazioni.
Abbiamo ottenuto molti risultati
grazie a questi test.
E non ci siamo focalizzati
solamente sugli edifici nuovi,
perché dovete capire che le aree
con più alto rischio sismico
sono anche quelle caratterizzate
da un patrimonio immobiliare
che si è costruito negli anni.
Quindi, con tecniche,
con materiali diversi,
e quindi noi abbiamo valutato
diversi materiali, diverse tecnologie
per poter migliorare il suo comportamento,
il loro comportamento.
Ad esempio, di strutture in muratura.
Tutto questo lavoro che abbiamo svolto
in collaborazione con altri centri di
ricerca in giro per l'Europa,
con altre università,
ha permesso di costituire
uno strumento utilissimo,
delle linee guida, degli standard
che ci hanno permesso
di costruire edifici più sicuri.
Questi standard sono noti
con il nome di ‘eurocodici’
e ci permettono di progettare,
realizzare e costruire
all'interno dell'Unione Europea
degli edifici sicuri.
Hanno un carattere innovativo,
tanto da essere preso in considerazione
anche al di fuori dell'Unione,
da Stati che li stanno valutando,
li stanno applicando
e li stanno utilizzando
perché li ritengono
uno strumento indispensabile.
Una parte degli eurocodici si dedica
alle costruzioni in zona sismica.
E fondamentalmente lì noi
ci poniamo tre obiettivi.
Il primo, il più importante:
la salvaguardia della vita umana.
Il secondo è quello di limitare
i danni causati da un terremoto.
Ed infine il terzo che si riferisce
a delle infrastrutture
cosiddette 'critiche’,
come gli ospedali,
gli edifici della Protezione Civile,
che devono rimanere operative
anche dopo un sisma eccezionale.
Come dicevo, tanti risultati
sono stati ottenuti,
però, ancora i terremoti ci colpiscono
e ancora portano devastazione.
Era il 2009
quando un sisma colpì L’Aquila
e causò più di 300 morti.
E poi, di nuovo, nel 2016
un altro sisma colpì una regione
tra L'Aquila, l'Abruzzo e le Marche.
E lì devastò decine di comuni,
e sotto le macerie delle proprie case
persero la vita quasi 300 persone.
Avrete capito bene che c'è
una chiave in tutta questa narrazione,
degli elementi importanti
che sono gli edifici.
Ma vi siete mai chiesti che impatto hanno
gli edifici sulla nostra vita?
O anche, più semplicemente,
quanto tempo trascorriamo
all'interno dei nostri edifici?
Quindici, sedici ore?
No, in realtà
ne trascorriamo molte di più.
Noi trascorriamo circa il 90%
della nostra vita dentro un edificio:
dalle ventuno alle ventidue ore,
tra casa, ufficio, scuola,
cinema, supermercati.
Se poi pensiamo all'impatto
che gli edifici hanno
sull'ambiente che ci circonda,
pensiamo semplicemente che ogni anno
viene prodotta una tonnellata
di calcestruzzo per essere umano
per costruire le nostre case,
le nostre scuole.
E quindi abbiamo iniziato a pensare a come
rendere più sostenibili i nostri edifici,
anche da un punto di vista energetico,
delle proprie performance
energetiche degli edifici.
Perché dovete ricordarvi che il 40% di
tutta l'energia che è consumata in Europa
è consumata dagli edifici.
E il 20% di questa energia letteralmente
'fluisce' fuori dai nostri muri,
dalle nostre finestre.
E allora abbiamo investito
tempo, denaro, ricerca
per poter migliorare
le performance energetiche:
nuovi materiali, nuovi isolamenti,
per rendere l’approvvigionamento
energetico dei nostri edifici migliore
attraverso pannelli solari.
Abbiamo iniziato ad appoggiare
pannelli solari
sopra tutti i tetti delle nostre città.
E se non mi credete, pensate,
siamo riusciti anche ad appoggiarli
sopra i tetti della Città del Vaticano.
Tutto questo va benissimo,
tutta questa attenzione che abbiamo posto
su questi concetti di sostenibilità,
di performance energetiche,
sono ottimi.
Ma noi poniamo la stessa attenzione
quando andiamo a considerare la sicurezza?
Quando stiamo comprando una nuova casa,
poniamo la stessa attenzione
alla sicurezza dentro questa casa
o alle case che viviamo tutt’oggi?
Oppure ci limitiamo a proteggerci
da possibili intrusioni,
completamente dimenticandoci i rischi
che ci pone la natura che ci circonda,
l’impatto che questa può avere
sui nostri edifici?
Ebbene,
noi dobbiamo porre attenzione
su questi temi,
sono temi fondamentali,
perché dobbiamo fermarci
e ricordarci che questi
sono temi importanti.
Perché poi, a un certo punto,
le notizie dei luoghi di devastazione
iniziano a svanire.
I media passano ad altri argomenti.
Le immagini dei luoghi di devastazione
diventano qualcosa di lontano,
un tragico ricordo,
qualcosa che è accaduto a qualcun altro.
Persino le persone vanno oltre
alle perdite di vite umane
che ci sono state in quegli eventi.
Noi pensiamo che sia qualcosa
che possa succedere a qualcun altro
ma non possa succedere a noi.
Ma così non è, e quindi
non dobbiamo dimenticare.
Dobbiamo fermarci a riflettere su
come poter fare per ridurre,
per evitare nuove devastazioni
come quelle che abbiamo visto.
E mi raccomando:
non basta che soltanto uno di noi
ponga attenzione a questi temi.
Perché se vogliamo avere
una comunità che sia 'resiliente'
- ossia che sia in grado di
rimettersi in piedi
dopo uno shock tremendo
come quello di un terremoto -
non basta uno di noi che ponga attenzione,
c'è bisogno di tutti noi,
di tutti i cittadini.
Dobbiamo andare oltre quei confini mentali
che ci fanno pensare che le cose,
le tragedie possano succedere agli altri.
O che ci fanno pensare solamente
alla relazione fra le nostre case
e l’ambiente che ci circonda
come qualcosa di unidirezionale.
Perché, in realtà,
non dobbiamo pensare solamente
all'impatto che i nostri edifici
hanno sulla natura,
ma anche a quello
che la natura pone come rischio
sui nostri edifici, sulle persone
che ci vivono al loro interno.
E dobbiamo agire, dobbiamo agire
per ridurre quei rischi.
La tecnologia per farlo c'è.
E dobbiamo agire ora,
perché sennò continueremo ad investire
milioni e milioni di euro
per appoggiare dei pannelli fotovoltaici
su dei castelli di carta.
Grazie.